[Music]
in a weekly tour news as in the weekly
leader or week as in like not strong not
strong perfect the founder of a popular
blog has deleted a post and thrown his
employee under the bus after people
hated it that's what I like these kinds
of I always want companies to do that
it's like hey we [ __ ] up at Starbucks
but really whose fault was it
it's our cashier Bob that was a dick man
we've been trying to get rid of him I
like that
I wish all company spoke like that would
you spoke speak like that would you
spoke like that my COO don't [ __ ] up my
COO don't [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
oh that's a good leader no it's just I'm
there always catch like cleaning up my
shoes they're always cleaning truth
surface bro yeah so have you guys heard
of the website called barstool sports
yes no I have the blog swallowing is
fitted making his lips and saying yes at
the same time in a very southern lady
voice it's because they have podcasts I
make up my own expressions there's this
writer there or actually he's not a
writer he's supposed to be the senior
director of editorial strategy and
growth yeah shut the hell that means
proofreading what is it again that's it
senior director of editorial strategy
and growth that's how they just you know
giving a promotion or a raise they just
give you more words in your title he's
the most important blogger
you know what's hilarious is when a lot
of these younger people they get a job
right out of college right and they
always had the same [ __ ] job but they
always try to make it sound like it's
more than it actually goes yeah well I
manage all the new media and I consult
the company in new media I was like
you're the Instagrammer in the company
you shut the [ __ ] up
all right don't you dare say that [ __ ]
to me like what the [ __ ] you take a
picture you choose a filter that's what
you use for this startup company where
basically I am the media influencer and
so you do the Instagram yes one that
kills me too is when the CEO contacts
you about this really big company that
they have and they want you to be a part
of it or whatever and you're like wait
but you're just stick to CEO like are
you doing all the grunt work so I just
be real man just say you like I just do
the Instagram stuff for now and that's
cool who you trying to impress man it's
okay they're learning everyone is
learning what the [ __ ] who are they
start at the beginning
no that's what I'm saying they start in
a very beginning and then they they they
try to look important and then they have
a business card that says CEO and
they'll be like hey man what's your name
what was that what you did a hundred
percent that's feel this [ __ ] I was the
guy we never did that
we had Uncle Sam Eloqua chair with the
American flag on there dude I was part
of a pyramid scheme and I said I was
part of marketing and promotions I
printed cards with two people shaking
hands on it it's like let's do business
oh yeah it's like like if I could give
that advice to people that is just don't
do that it makes you look more
incompetent but if you don't do it
though you don't you don't learn you
gotta go through the embarrassing time I
was 19
yeah I approached a lot of companies to
sell the service as an employee benefit
through HR and I was only 19 so they all
actually were kind of impressed that I
even was approaching them and I sold
some employee benefits that's tight but
just didn't I looked stupid
later I'm like a ho man how much it was
man
yeah so this dude with the longest job
title his name is Chris Spagnuolo aka
Chris bag and so yeah alright that's a
very very unattractive name man yes bugs
who Specter he he wrote a blog post with
the headline that says is Rihanna going
to make being fat the hot new trend
oh no she the fat [ __ ] you yeah a little
actually good I haven't see her too long
I'm wearing her highlight dude put on a
little bit of weight she's thick her
normal she's a snack though but she's
always using a heavy snack okay a heavy
lunch he's good
ain't nothing wrong with that I own it
yeah so a little excerpt what his vlog
said would you like to read this yep
with all the fat acceptance and love me
as I am crowd there's definitely a world
where I could see chicks see Rihanna
makes some strong I don't give a [ __ ] I
just love pizza quote that goes viral
and bam we're in a world where all the
hottest girls look like the humans in
wall-e
time for summer to a world of ladies
shaped like the Hindenburg loaded into
one piece bathing suits may be on the
horizon now that rihanna is traipsing
around out there looking like she's in a
sumo suit that is so [ __ ] is a dead
hilarious and wrong what a [ __ ]
yeah yeah one more sentence it's a
dangerous precedent and you may want to
start adjusting your porn browsing to
primarily be BW porn to condition
yourself to this dystopian future we now
face he's popular with the [ __ ] women
W Joe uh-huh big beautiful women yeah so
that was like just a little piece of his
his original blog so loser
and so he's tweeting this out cuz
Rihanna got moody he said Rihanna fans
did not like my blog calling her fat and
now I'm being cyberbullied
newsela screams [ __ ] yo something tells
me that you don't have to worry about
whether Rihanna or Ashley grandma
retract to you dear sir beautiful nobody
likes white men okay what
she didn't have to blink it all when you
are typical white trash that was some of
the screenshots like you posted in that
tweet oh I see so he was just trying to
find racist ones yeah yeah have y'all
seen Ashley grant oh she's falling I
know she's she's so and then so he ends
up tweeting also this thanks lady it's
just the life in the field my guarantee
99% of angry tweets didn't read it and
main assumptions of the headline well
you wrote the headline [ __ ] and we
read the article and it was really bad
pretty bad a guy's an idiot then that
blog posts obviously receive a ton of
backlash and then so they're saying that
even like so many people hated this post
that even one of the sites own employees
tweeted out when the squad finally gets
the Brant to not be synonymous with
sexism and then someone writes this for
attention and then she tweets that the
links of that and then she also tweets
I'd say we should adopt by dip shits for
dip shits but then some faceless
basement dweller would put this tweet in
a shitty article so that was the whole
thing there it meant dweller I like that
and then the founder Dave Portnoy he
published a blog this company has a lot
of interesting names the probably from
the East Coast or some [ __ ] oh yeah he
was saying that pretty much you were
just throwing this employee under the
bus thing like he's not worth fighting
for that's not a hill I'm gonna die on
and like let's move on time he was here
he said that and he educated us on what
that I don't know what that segment
people ways uses like phrases that we
never hear of like amen that's your
tissue box to wipe your ass with all
right then I bet you that's real [ __ ]
that's your chicken leg run with it find
a hill to die on yeah yeah who knew that
in this cruel
I know find a hole and crawl in it yeah
I know that one find a hole and crawling
it yeah that's right that's that's good
I know that make like a tree and leave
whoa almost you almost didn't know it
was a maker in church and split that's
how I make like a deck of cards and
shuffle like an American marriage and
split so this founder here he's just
people are just pointing out like wow
you're just throw your employee under
the bus just cuz a lot of people didn't
like that blog post cuz he's wheel
though just kind of cool cuz originally
he's saying here that Spags wasn't
originally hired to be a personality at
barstool that he should not be writing
blogs that the company would end up
having to defend and yeah the whole
Diana Hill thing but he's a senior
executive of vice president marketing
that's pretty high position yeah but I I
don't think that's like throwing your
employee under the bus cuz let's say
it's just like disavowing yeah cuz like
let's say Starbucks had an employee they
started saying racial slurs yeah they'll
denounce them too you know what I mean
so that's not throwing them under the
bus as I say that doesn't represent my
company right I think as a owner you're
allowed to say that I think so too
cuz it seems like the the person that
wrote this they're very biased against
bar stool like they just don't like bar
stools oh right sure how come the CEO
didn't come out and say miss Biggs you
stupid things like did Spags get fired
ah and he's just like doing janitor work
now I think I think they I think they
did fire senior janitorial services
executive how come he doesn't like
Rihanna so much trash inspector I think
his article is trying to talk about or
he's expressing his opinions about this
body acceptance movement because there's
this like gray area where there's people
who say like yeah you should love
yourself but you can't take away from
the fact that where's there's help and
then there's love you know what I mean I
think he's trying to hit on that topic
in a very disgusting you know what I'm
saying because they come from a place of
deeper meaning
this guy is horny and now one of his
[ __ ] I
Hans is ruined and what's [ __ ] up is
he he should I think what he was
probably trying to it was the whole
health part of it but just because
you're skinny do doesn't mean you're
[ __ ] right either and he didn't even
mention health at all he just mentioned
girls and bikinis being fat now well
that was just like an excerpt of the
blog I'm not sure what what the rest of
the blog said because they deleted it
got it so that was just the part that
this specific article that he was like a
message to all dudes to update their
porn you know it's like yeah that
doesn't sound like I'm happy that
badasses in yeah hell yeah Vic yeah
there's the comment to cease yeah
there's a comment on this article where
someone says that later Spags
ended up apologizing if anyone was
offended but that his personal animosity
toward fat people is because his own
father spent years of his life I thought
[ __ ] you fighting the noisy 22 I feel
like he's like 23 22 like a young dude
I'm sad because my back outside a day my
dad died you better be attractive
talking like shitty not that's in
himself yeah he's like I'm metrosexual
it's like the thickness of Rihanna
perhaps yeah yeah yeah it's all the guys
that are not like in shape themselves or
like why isn't this celebrity and shape
Adeeb or I wanted her to be in shape
dungeon dwellers dungeon dweller I like
that better than basement dweller
[Music]